all hell breaks loose it box when the
boss unleashes hell on a top staffer
racial issues continue to rile the
nation and nasty debate breaks out over
reopening schools I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show Ben Shapiro show
is sponsored by expressvpn don't let
others trap what do keep yourself safe
and express it VPN comm slash Ben we're
gonna get to all the news in just one
moment first let me remind you things
are really really volatile right now
particularly in world markets if you got
money in the stock market been watching
this thing bounce up and down like a
yo-yo you just have no idea where the
market is going next with coronavirus
and with race riots and with the
presidential election they're just too
much news to really price into the
market right now and that is why you're
seeing so much uncertainty out there
this is why it might be a good time to
at least be a little bit diversified one
of the ways the hedge against risk and
by the way also hedge against inflation
that will come sooner or later given the
way we are spending money like a drunken
sailor one of the ways to do that invest
in precious metals at least a little bit
this is why you should talk to my
friends over at Birch gold group your
grandkids will be paying for everything
that is going on right now so it might
be worthwhile to at least give them some
money to do so by diversifying ten
twenty percent your portfolio into
precious metals and Birch gold group can
help you out text Ben to 47 47 47 when
you purchase on or before July 31st you
get a free signed copy of my book the
right side of history Birch gold will go
to work for you and make things super
simple they're the people I trust with
precious metals investing I know people
who run the place I really think that
they are honest text Ben - 47 47 47 at
least request a free information kit on
diversifying in school again always ask
all your questions get all the
information feel as comfortable as you
could feel before you invest but people
at Birch gold can help guide you X Ben -
47 47 47 and during the months of June
or July when you open an IRA and
precious metals get a signed copy of my
book the right side of history for free
again text my name Ben - 47 47 47 all
right so all hell has broken loose over
there on the left on the left there's
this internecine war that is now going
on between
old school liberals and the hard left
and you've seen hints of this before
Nancy Pelosi was going at it with the
squad you've seen hints of it it places
like Evergreen State College where Brett
Weinstein who's a socialist I mean an
actual member of the political left that
was basically cast out of the college
and was threatened
with physical violence for not just for
deciding to teach in spite of a call
from not to teach because of his race
and their been sort of hints at it here
and there but now it is broken into
full-scale warfare particularly inside
the nation's institutions that are not
universities I think it's important to
note this stuff has been happening on
universities for a very long time right
the only Nicholas Christakis / a Yale
being ousted from the campus for the
great sin of having said people where
Halloween costumes sometimes you've seen
college campuses trying to ban speech
from people ranging from me to Heather
McDonald to charles murray like
everybody on the right or anywhere near
to the right has been basically canceled
from at least one campus or been
threatened with violence for appearing
at a campus and this sort of stuff
happens all the time but the Liberals in
the media particularly they didn't want
to believe this was coming for them they
wanted to believe that this was only
aimed at the right and so the way they
shied away from this is by saying a
couple things one this is just
enthusiasm on college campuses it's just
too enthusiastic right I mean these are
people they're young they make mistakes
but we need their enthusiasm to really
drive the movement forward we need to
channel that enthusiasm and as they grow
and as they mature as they enter the
real world some of those rough edges
will be sort of sanded off but we
certainly don't want to denounce their
behavior right now and we certainly
don't want to magnify it or pretend that
it's outsized or means anything it
doesn't mean anything and the right is
constantly pouncing on college campuses
and using college campuses as a sort of
example of how radical we are come on
guys those are just college campuses at
the same time people who are doing this
stuff they're good-hearted and so can we
really blame them that was one angle
that was being used right was that these
are college campuses and so that's
nothing like how the real world is going
to work in the second angle that was
being used is these are enthusiastic
people who are gonna become our people
now as you may have noticed from the
last few years in politics as soon as
you say to the most radical elements of
your membership that you need their
passion they immediately take over the
entire party right that is the way that
it works as soon as you say to a group
of people who are sort of on the fringe
that you need their passion to drive us
forward they take over the part you seen
this with Bernie Sanders inside the
Democratic Party you could certainly say
that this happened inside the Republican
Party in 2016 with President Trump is
that there was this very disaffected
populace who basically that a lot of
people you could see this with all the
other presidential campaigns the other
presidential campaigns did not want to
hit Trump directly because they were
saying well eventually Trump will follow
away and will need this
support of these people and their
passion really means something so Trump
just takes over the park you're a bit
the same this sort of stuff happens in
political movements all the time well
now it turns out at the lefts cancel
culture that started on campuses has
moved into mainstream liberalism and it
turns out that mainstream liberalism had
no immune system for this now normally
you have to have an immune system
against bad stuff happening inside your
political movement and the immune system
relies on you being able to toss people
and elements out of your movement when
you don't like what they are doing
to say certain tactics are off limits in
your movement the problem is that the
mainstream liberal left didn't have an
immune system for the hardcore left
because basically all the hardcore left
is they just extended the arguments of
mainstream liberals a little bit in ways
that the mainstream liberals just could
not fight back against so let me explain
what I mean here
so the difference I think between
liberals and the hard left in the United
States is that liberals in the United
States were all about fighting
inequality from within the system right
this is what liberals in the United
States used to share with sort of
classical liberals or even conservatives
was the idea the American system wasn't
necessarily inherently bad it just had
some problems with it and if we just
fixed the problems we tinker with the
problems in a technocratic way if we
harnessed the power of the American
economy if we harness capitalism to a
bunch of regulations and we can end up
with something that looks a lot more
like Europe a lot more equal in outcome
now what the left and liberals held in
common
was a goal of ending inequality and not
of inequality of opportunity or
inequality of Rights ending inequality
of outcome right that's was the left and
liberals held in common what the left
and liberals were divided about was
working within the system or working to
destroyed the system from outside and so
these two groups both liberals and and
the left they decided to basically make
a common cause okay well we're not sure
whether we're gonna tear down the system
or whether we're going to work with
inside inside the system but we have a
common enemy and that common enemy is
the right and the right must be fought
so you saw these two groups of people
basically combining forces and this is
sort of the difference between a radical
left wing of the Democratic Party that
was riding at the 1968 Chicago
Convention and the Hubert Humphrey wing
of the Democratic Party that was still
in charge of the party in 1968 you've
seen this debate play out for decades
inside the Democratic Party one group of
Democrats basically saying that the
system itself is not completely broken
it's not completely wrong it doesn't
have to be in completely
officiated what you have to do is work
tinker inside the system and we draw
closer every day to utopia but you can't
tear down the entire system because well
we don't like some of the roots of the
system we do like some of the things
about the system like we still like the
culture of Rights this is why the ACLU
used to be monk very much in favor of
freedom of speech and the radicals like
know all of this is bad
right everything has to go we need to
tear everything down in neo-marxist
fashion we need to build up a new
Marxist utopia
so that divide was there but it was
papered over by general opposition's to
the right now liberals always had the
upper hand here because the mainstream
American population was never in favor
of tearing down the system and when the
Democratic Party was most successful
historically
is when the Democratic Party was making
the liberal argument not the hard left
argument whenever the Democratic Party
made the hard left argument the
Democratic Party lost whenever the
Democratic Party argued we're tearing
down the entire system then they realize
the American people are not up for that
the American people and like the
American system and so liberals always
had the upper hand inside the party but
the problem and this was the pitch the
Liberals made was you know the reason
you on the Left you need to deal with us
is because we can channel your program
into action points that are palatable to
the American people but here's the
problem
the Liberals never had any immune system
against the arguments of left basically
soul-sucking them why well because the
the Liberals made a move in the 1960s
that they really never liked though and
really opened them up their their own
case for maintaining the system it
opened them up to a critique from the
radical left that they simply could not
revive so what was that argument well in
the 1960s the left began to make the
argument that if you were against their
programs if you were against their
political programs that stood in favor
of ending inequality right we're working
within the system 10 in equality was the
argument if you were against any of
those programs it's because secretly you
were racist and the rosehip this over
and over and over again and the right
couldn't understand it
I mean the right got this all the time
if you were in favor of welfare reform
it's because we were secretly a racist
if you're against Obama care it's
because you're secretly a racist if you
were against any of the left's programs
liberals programs in terms of shifting
the the nature of American government is
because you were secretly a racist right
so they allied with the radical racial
movement - its racialized everything in
order to again push forward so the
liberal left which one is work within
the system
built alliances with two groups of
people now we wanted to tear down the
system one radical racialist who saw the
entire system as an outgrowth of
American brutality and to neo-marxists
we wanted to see the entire system
ripped down about their ears okay and
liberals were like okay we still have
the upper hand here we still the upper
hand now the problem is that by opening
it by bringing everybody into this fold
and creating this alliance
the Liberals basically made themselves a
minority inside their own movement and
how did this work so basically you had a
bunch of people who said listen when we
say that you stand in favor of systems
you on the right that you stand in favor
of systems that perpetuate inequality
and so we want to change those systems
because that's racist that you want
perpetuate inequality that does the
argument liberals make the Left said
it's not just that the systems have to
be changed from the inside to stop
racism the systems have to be torn down
as a whole to stop racism in fact every
elements of the system has to be torn
down to stop racism and the Liberals
wanted to maintain at least some
semblance of the system were taken aback
by this argument they had no immune
system to this argument they've been
using the exact same argument to attack
the right for years for years the attack
on the right had been you guys are
secretly racist because you don't
discuss you don't agree with us and then
the left's head to the Liberals you guys
are secretly racist because you don't
agree with us and liberals had no
comeback to that because they've been
using the same exact argument for
literally decades now normally there'd
be a couple of pushback points from the
Liberals to the left here
one would be guys we can't win like this
I turn down the system is not a winning
strategy tearing down the system is not
going to be successful right this had
always been the liberal talking point
against the hard left which is we're
gonna take no more radical viewpoints
we're going to channel them into a more
palatable forms of the American people
and then we will win a broad victory but
if it's just you guys your rump right
you don't actually have enough votes in
order to win things well now the left
says to the Liberals guys have you seen
our cultural dominance have you seen the
kind of cultural power we can exert have
you seen the fact that we can take shows
off the air have you seen the fact that
we can take over Hollywood we can take
over mainstream at media institutions
have you seen the fact that we can Club
people into submission have you seen
this don't pretend that we are the
minority anymore we are now the majority
right we have a coalition of the
dispossessed or at least the purport
dispossessed and we are going to
mobilize against the system and you guys
are standing in our way you're either
with us or you're against us so point
number one that the Liberals had against
the left was gone right because the left
said listen you've been saying we need
you for victory what if we don't need
you for victory right what if actually
if you join us we have victory and what
if the left sides behind Bernie Sanders
and maybe we can still win and this
begins to look much more like a
plausible outcome when they are running
against somebody like Donald Trump
because they say everybody hates Trump
so much that you know we can be as hard
left as we want to be and we don't need
you to uphold the system anymore so that
was point number one that the Liberals
used to use against the left and that
the left is basically destroyed point
number two is that the liberals used to
have a principled point with regards to
the left which was listen even if we are
the majority the reality is that one of
the ways we became the majority is by
using many of the rights there now to
crime right the rights of freedom of
speech we used to at least to like that
thing because that was what gave us the
power to overcome cultural culturally a
mobile obstacles right it was the way
that we overcame that is the right had
certain cultural dominance we used
freedom of speech in order to overcome
that sort of dominance and so the
institution of freedom of speech is
inherently good right and you can't just
you can't just tear down systems that
infringe people's rights the left you
sit some people are in the liberal left
used to believe in rights and the left
said oh no you're getting this all wrong
you're getting this all wrong
rights are not even implicated here guys
rights are not even implicated what
we're doing is we're trying to stop
violence we're trying to stop violence
and you are complicit in violence if you
stand for right so let's came up with a
clever tactic right this is this started
on college campus with all the safety
ISM the argument is that if I say
something you don't like it is not and
I'm exercising my freedom of speech and
we ought to have a discussion it is that
I am enacting violence upon you until
rights are not implicated anymore rights
themselves in fact are a shield for
violence being done and again the
Liberals really had no comeback to this
because the Liberals had been using very
similar arguments on a variety of issues
liberals would be using this argument
for example on freedom of association
right they said freedom of association
is bad the federal government now has to
regulate freedom of association because
some people misuse freedom of
association they don't want to associate
with people because they're racists for
example and therefore freedom of
association
cannot be used as an excuse to do bad
things and so the hard left head okay
well if that applies to freedom of
association and it also applies to
things like freedom of speech and so
freedom of speech has to be curtailed in
order to protect people's feelings
because people's people's lives are
being ruined people are feeling unsafe
and so the less the left has basically
co-opted the the mainstream liberal
movement and this is what you're getting
is all a big lead up to what you are
seeing right now in mainstream media
institutions around the country major
institutions around the country as
liberals I think are giving sort of
their final gasp of breath before they
are drowned in the bathtub of leftism
hey that's what's happening right now
what's happening right now is that the
Liberals having having thought all along
that this alliance was going to serve
them it turns out that that the
molotov-ribbentrop pact has now been
broken right and it turns out that
somebody's invading the Soviet Union
right that it turns out that the the the
heretofore alliance was always a shield
for a betrayal that was going to come
and take over leadership there was gonna
be an internal battle liberals didn't
expect it and now they're looking around
they're going oh wait a second Oh No
right the Committee on Public Safety
they're the first people to the
guillotines as it turns out that if you
humor at all these folks and eventually
they would turn on you and figure
they'll never turn on us they're just
you know we'll use their passion this
the Liberals felt about the mainstream
left that the big radical left the same
way they felt about the college campus
kids well we'll humor them we'll toss
him a bone they'll provide the passion
they'll provide the impetus well Pat
them on the head and we'll tell them
that they're doing nice good things and
then everything will be okay right we'll
just work with them even though they're
really really radical and then left so
think what if we don't want to work with
you what if instead we want you to
become an adjunct to us we are sick of
riding shotgun what if we take the wheel
and you ride shotgun for a little while
and the Liberals have no idea how to
counter this and so instead they're
signing open letters saying we support
freedom of speech and then they're being
cancelled or doing so you can see this
playing out in the halls of voxcom
one of the less good publications on the
internet we'll get to the battle that's
broken out at box.com cuz it is quite
fascinating and indicative of exactly
what is happening inside the West versus
liberal internal battle now normally by
the way I would say I would just sit
back
enjoy this right I mean this is like a
bunch of people who I'm not necessarily
the most fond of who are eating each
other but I think that the Liberals
their perspective must be upheld here
because if you're going to have an
alliance at this point in American life
that allows for conversation
the Liberals have to win this battle
with the left I think right now they're
losing and they're losing pretty badly
I'll get to this in just for one second
first blink sale okay let's talk about
the fact that invoicing can be a giant
pain in the butt invoice a great go to
Microsoft Word you did a job for
somebody write up the invoice you send
it to them and then you completely
forget you send somebody the invoice you
have no follow-up
it doesn't look good there are no
systems of tracking and you lose money
this way I don't even know who's dodging
your bills well this is why you require
blink sale with blink sale you can send
beautiful custom branded invoices and
estimates in seconds you can stay on top
of your outstanding invoices you can let
your customers and clients easily pay
your invoices online you'll even get
instant notifications when a customer
opens your invoice so you'll actually
know if they're just avoiding paying you
forget about using invoice templates or
stressing about coordinating a bunch of
different software programs blink sale
takes care of it all so you can spend
more time focusing on the work it
actually gets you paid and makes your
business a success as an added bonus
blink sale is now giving away 10 bucks
to 500 daily wire fan so here's how it
works but a blink sale comm start your
14 day free trial create your first
invoice of 10 bucks activate an online
payment option stripe or PayPal send the
invoice to daily wire at blink sale comm
and they'll just paid 10 bucks the first
500 people to send an invoice for $10
today Lee Weyer at blink sale comm will
get their invoice paid I blink sale
limit of one per person and you
shouldn't have to send nagging emails
get your invoice paid you should just be
able to automate all this stuff and make
it really easy for you stop wasting your
time invoicing trebling sale for free at
blink sale comm is /bin that's bo i NK
si le comm / been linked sale comm / men
go check them out right now okay so
cancel culture has now come for voxcom
so voxcom
a supposed explanatory journalism
website it is very much of the political
left and let's be frank about this box
comm has for a very long time been on
the side of the cancel culture right
they've been deeply enmeshed in the
cancel culture when steven crowder said
some not very nice things about carlos
maza who was then working for box carlos
maas acclaimed publicly that he had been
victimized and that he was his feelings
had been hurt his safety had been
imperiled because somebody
had mean words about him on the
interwebs which as a person who's I
think it's fair to say I'd taken my fair
share of mean words on the interwebs
it's like come on get over it dude like
seriously just move on with your life
grow a thicker skin as as Don Lemon
might say just grow a thicker skin but
box went all out and tried to have
steven crowder basically banned from the
YouTube platform like they issued a full
letter from the editorial board trying
to ban skew it so they've been very
involved in canceled culture for a long
time but one of the people over at
voxcom Matthew Iglesias again is not a
person who I think I have spoken about
positively much on this program other
than maybe in the last couple of months
when it seems like he has had an
awakening to the fact that free speech
is actually a good thing
Iglesias signed on to this Harper's
Weekly letter that was signed by a
hundred and fifty different people all
of whom were from Center to central left
I would say the most right-wing figures
there or people like David Fromm and not
a single Trump voter among them
obviously it was signed by about a
hundred and fifty intellectuals in
pseudo-intellectuals like Noam Chomsky
and and it was basically just a
statement that we don't like cancel
culture so Glacia signed it and he was
immediately hit within accusation by one
of his own staffers who is a trans woman
meaning biological male who believes
that he is a female that that Iglesias
was somehow threatening his safety right
to that Iglesias was somehow targeting
him which is patently absurd there's
nothing in the letter about trans issues
at all in fact a couple of different
trans people signed the letter because
it had it had nothing to do with trans
issues is this person sends this letter
an open letter right on the interwebs
just throws it out there to the editors
of voxcom now Ezra Klein is one of the
heads of box nine I mean I believe is
that technically editor-in-chief I'm not
sure what Ezra I don't think so I think
some somebody else is the actual
editor-in-chief of box come but Ezra is
a high-ranking staffer use that he's a
co-founder at box he's currently editor
at large over there I believe so Ezra
obviously very high-ranking staffer over
there and Ezra who's always been semi
warm toward canceled culture and he can
view our Sunday special that I did with
him I got a perfectly nice guy
Ezra Klein but not somebody who's fought
very hard against cancer culture and in
fact is sort of sat there sort of
cheering it for a while Ezra Klein and
Matthew Iglesias get into a flame war
now remember Iglesias is another
co-founder of Vox
right Matthew Iglesias and and and Ezra
Klein were the word I believe cofounders
of this thing in 2014 he's currently an
editor and columnist over at voxcom so
Glacia signs this letter and then he
gets him to a flame war with Ezra Klein
and meanwhile other people at voxcom are
basically flaming like really flaming
Iglesias online and here's and here's
how it happened so here are some of the
tweets it started flying back and forth
last night about canceled culture so so
what happened is that Iglesias tweeted
out
I've committed to not doing contentious
stuff on Twitter anymore so I seriously
can't get comments on this I would
appreciate being taken out of the thread
there was a whole thread about Iglesias
and whether he was sort of being
cancelled from within over at voxcom and
then as recline basically sub tweeted
Matthew Iglesias ranked he sub tweeted
him he tweeted a lot of debates that
sell themselves as being about free
speech are actually about power and
there's a lot of power and being able to
claim and hold the mantle of free speech
defender said his as recline dishonestly
suggesting the exact radical left
rationale for shutting down freedom of
speech if you stand for freedom of
speech what you're actually standing for
is evil people taking advantage of
freedom of speech and Matthew Iglesias
that's what you're actually rights it's
very obvious subtweet there's only one
reason that Ezra Klein is tweeting about
this which makes him kind of a nasty
person right I mean this is pretty nasty
stuff to take the co-founder of your
website who signed a letter that
basically says free speech is good in
canceled culture is bad and then tweet a
crucially what he means actually what he
means is he wants to be powerful he gets
power out defending free speech first of
all let me just make something perfectly
clear on the Left today there is no
power in claiming you are about free
speech on the Left today none okay like
the amount of power and and prestige to
be earned on the political left for
being Pro free speech is very low by the
way it ain't that high on the right
either because I end up having to defend
a lot of people that the right doesn't
like particularly much I've ended up
defending people like James Gunn on this
show I've ended up defending people on
this show who have been hired by the New
York Times after saying anti white stuff
like does it I've defended a wide
variety of people you're not gonna earn
friends and influence people really by
defending free speech but according to
Ezra Klein if you say you're for free
speech you are for the range from inner
power which is a trick that Ezra does a
lot and I find it really really ugly is
this idea that when
you say one thing what you actually mean
is this other thing well you you don't
even know what you actually are about is
Rhian training hierarchies of power and
that's what Ezra Klein says about
Iglesias
so then Iglesias fires back should I
reply to this with a concrete example or
stick to my commitments to you which is
basically him saying like do you want me
to violate my confidentiality that are
signed with voxcom and the commitments
that I've signed to box.com and personal
commitments like your flaming me online
but I'm not gonna flame you is what
Iglesias is saying right there okay then
wait so it appeared like people online
are speculating that basically it looks
like bas gonna fire a glaze yes right
yeah it's not me right at Yasha monk
over at the Atlantic is sort of
suggesting that this looks very much
like a path like Ezra Klein's talking
about power here Ezra Klein is editor at
large and co-founder of ox there's a
little bit of weight over there
so then Iglesias and Ezra Klein at the
very end of the night they decide that
they're gonna go sort of weapons down so
Iglesias tweets out I would like to
deescalate this nobody is losing their
job I think I've spoken my mind very
clearly on this subject I'm just trying
to move on to other things instead of
endless rounds with Twitter wrangling
which of course is not what's going on
at all basically he is trying to keep
silence that he's not Elstad from
box.com
and publicly bashed by his former
co-founder partner as recline and then
as recline does the same thing as her
client they must come to some sort of
agreement as a recline tweets out the
idea that I would try to get mad
literally my co-founder and the oldest
friend in journalism fired over this
letter is risible I've asked Matt and
others at box to not subtweet colleagues
my mistake here is this sweet red like a
sub sweet of him when it honestly wasn't
I'm sure that it was not a sub tweet of
Iglesias sure sure it wasn't subdued
with glacis the bottom line is that
these sort of a Glacia sources crying
battle inside box calm is quite
indicative of the extent which the
radical left has influenced the debate
right that is the real key here is that
there's a whole contingent to box that
doesn't like free speech there's a whole
contingent to box that wants canceled
culture to win and it's he's canceled
culture as an ultimate good and it's his
rights as an obstacle to the building of
a new society the radical left has
attacked the Liberals and many people
who are sort of wavering like I think
Ezra was kind of wavering here some of
the people who may have been wavering or
reportedly publicly wavering are not
wavering much anymore obviously
now this has er actually had the power
to fire Iglesias know that the actual
see I see a box is a woman in Bourne
Williams we tweeted out proof the two
not real life in real life I'm the EIC a
box and the effing boss I don't tweet so
folks who don't know or work with me
seem to think a variety of other people
wield that power okay well if you're the
EIC a box you might want to get your
house under control lady I mean like let
me just put it this way I am the I am
the founder of daily wire and if people
inside my shop or subtweeting other
people inside my shop the way that this
is going on a box somebody would be on
the breadline tomorrow right this is not
the way you run a business but again the
way that you run a business now is to
basically let your woke staffers control
the whole thing and the Liberals do the
Liberals have an immune system to this I
really wonder i really wonder because
once you have that combination of tear
down the system and also anyone who says
don't tear down the system is a racist
once you have moved from traditional
liberal views of racism to the anti
racism of the abram candy robin angelo
crowd there is no immune system among
liberals to fight this i think the
battle is over and I think that the
Liberals just haven't acknowledged it
yet or they're gonna have to acknowledge
the dare on the outside of their own
party and I think that it let me just
say this I've spoken to many many
liberals at mainstream organizations in
the past three weeks
I never revealed who I talk to because I
understand the way this works if they
say they've ever had a conversation with
me they're immediately canceled right I
can say I could say it with no fear
right I can say it because guess what I
don't care but if you're a liberal
working inside a mainstream media
organization you can't say you've ever
had a conference to me publicly if you
ever glanced um you publicly you might
get canceled let me just say I've gotten
a bevy of text not just from one or two
people from many many people
or mainstream liberals asking me what
the hell is going on like guys sorry
that you're late to the party sorry I've
been warning you about this for a while
they just just I hate to break it to you
but welcome I feel like Bruce Willis in
die hard looking down and Carl man
welcome to the party pal is that as the
shots rain down from the third floor
from Hans Gruber's crew it's pretty
incredible
me well you know how much the so a
couple of the key arguments that have
been made here by the by the radical
left you can see that again their
argument is not absolutely wrong right
the Liberals made a couple of arguments
one is that rights are good and the
second is that if you don't adopt our
tactics you're going to lose and the
radical left is like well we don't have
to adopt our tactics we could just tear
down the entire system and we'll win I'm
gonna show you evidence that the radical
left is not wrong here the radical left
is not incorrect here when you get to
that
in just one second first let us talk
about the fact that there hasn't been a
whole lot to smile about these last few
months I mean pretty bit been pretty
miserable but things are getting better
I know you don't believe me but they do
they they will they will get better and
you should be able to smile at some
point at some point in the future when
smiling is no longer canceled you want
your teeth to look absolutely
fan-freakin'-tastic and this is why you
need candidate clear aligners they're
comfortable removable totally invisible
unlike wire braces so you can transform
your smile without anyone noticing plus
your treatment is prescribed and
monitored remotely by a licensed
orthodontist who's an expert in tooth
chans it only works with orthodontists
never general dentists like other
companies and with some of these other
companies you may never hear from a
doctor as you go through treatment which
is kind of ridiculous frankly with
Canton your treatment includes remote
monitoring by the same orthodontist who
created your plan so you never have to
wonder how you're doing you will always
know which is just fantastic I mean
right now is not the world's best time
to go to the orthodontist generally and
candidate makes things easier than going
to the orthodontist anyway the average
can of treatment six months cost an
average of 50 percent less and
Invisalign if you're ready to take the
first step toward your dream smile and
you can't wait to show it off it started
today from the comfort of your own home
with Canada's risk-free starter kit and
75 bucks off go to candid co.com slash
Shapiro use code Shapiro that's candid
co.com slash capiro code Shapiro for
your risk free starter kit and 75 bucks
off candid co.com slash Shapiro code
Shapiro okay so as the as the Liberals
lost I think their unity with the
country as they began to give ground
overtime so the radical left that
claimed the entire system was corrupt
and evil and anybody who opposed
institutional change was racist as that
happened as they went along with the
full-scale destruction of America's
history culture philosophy the
destruction of the elements which I talk
about in my upcoming book comes out very
very soon now I'm week-and-a-half
menu book how to destroy America in
three easy steps as the as the Liberals
and the left basically formed an
alliance to go along with the
destruction of these things in pursuit
of political power it turns out that the
West gained the upper hand because as
the culture change right as people began
to accept liberal arguments that to
oppose changes to the system was in fact
a race in elements of racism in elements
of bigotry the great stain on American
history okay as people began to accept
this the left began to credibly make the
argument in the institutions of power
that they could make as radical an
argument as they
we wanted and people would basically go
along with it and they're they're not
wrong I mean this is they've spent an
enormous amount of time an inordinate
amount of money people on the radical
left to push this message they've
captured institutions they've
participated in institutional capture
the most obvious example of the
institutional capture is of course the
16:19 project the 16:19 project by the
way want one of my favorite things about
the New York Times their dishonesty is
just astonishing
the New York Times spends day after day
after day trying to brow B companies
like Facebook into shutting down all the
outlets they don't particularly like the
New York Times has column after column
suggesting that Facebook is evil and
horrible and risible and terrible
because they allow sites like Daily wire
to exist and monetize you know that this
kind of stuff is very bad according to
the New York Times every single day
there's a columnist at the New York
Times well tweet out how popular my
facebook pages and it's like well thanks
dude what he's really doing obviously is
he suggesting that Facebook is evil for
allowing my page to be popular listen
it's not my fault that you write good
headlines over at the Daily wire and
people want to click on our stuff you
jerk but the reason that people at the
New York Times are doing that is because
the New York Times is simultaneously
dropping millions and millions of
dollars in marketing on Facebook you
know how much money the New York Times
spent on a 16:19 project marketing there
there's a good story over at Daily wire
today by the new editor-in-chief over
there John Buckley in which he talks
about how much money the New York Times
has spends on the 16:19 projects
according to the marketing intelligence
platform path Maddox the New York Times
which is spends all of its time
suggesting other outlets should
basically be shut down on Facebook the
New York Times spends around 65 million
dollars over the course of the last 12
months on Facebook advertising for all
of its various promotional campaigns a
review of just three ads promoting the
16:19 project which of course reimagine
America as a racist telescope from
inception to now over the course of
about two months in fall 2019 estimates
a spend of around three million dollars
for three ads three ads basically the
New York Times used Facebook to purchase
a Pulitzer for Nicole Hannah Jones
essentially what happened here okay so
the radical left they can credibly make
the arguments liberals listen we don't
need you guys we don't need your
soft-pedaling we can go as hard as we
want I mean the : Hannah just what a
racist else Cape America is I mean
what's hilarious about this is the more
the radical left takes over the
institution
of American culture the harder their
argument should actually become because
their argument particularly the racially
radical left their arguments that
America's racist tell escape bigoted
evil in every way and at the same time
they're in charge of all the major
cultural institutions of the country
right Colin Kapernick is earning
millions of dollars from Disney for some
sort of first look deal plus millions of
dollars from Nike for kneeling Nicole
Hannah Jones who spends her entire life
talking about how racist America is is
now working with Oprah Winfrey perhaps
the richest woman on planet earth a
black woman from America partnering with
Lionsgate to bring the New York Times's
project to a series of films and TV
shows does this sound like people who
are shut out of the halls of power by a
racist hell escape system apparently the
answer is yes but the broader argument
the left to make now is listen we're in
control we don't need to tolerate rights
anymore now you used to need it you used
to need those things like freedom of
speech in order to push your point of
view because it turns out that most
Americans didn't agree with it we don't
need freedom of speech anymore
we control the means of distribution we
control the dissemination of information
and if we don't then we'll try to bully
platforms into mirroring us right we'll
try to bully Facebook into shutting down
all other dissemination of information
once the left has taken the reins its
totalitarian I mean that that is what is
going on here according to the New York
Times Pulitzer prize-winning journalist
Nicole Hannah Jones and the New York
Times have chosen global content leader
Lionsgate to be the home for a
wide-ranging partnership to develop miss
Hannah Jones his landmark issue of the
New York Times Magazine the 16:19
project and hit New York town of podcast
1619 into an expansive portfolio of
feature films TV series and other
content for a global audience Wow visit
I met what a racist hell escaped America
is what a terrible terrible place where
people of color simply cannot get ahead
like Nicole Hannah Jones who's made a
living an incredible living an
incredible profile out of suggesting
that America is from root to branch the
worst place ever really amazing stuff so
again the left's argument is really
effective against liberals they say
listen we don't need any of those rights
that used to talk about it world enough
to remember when you used to say things
like we'll defend your right to say
anything even if we disagree with it but
we don't because really what you're
doing is you're enabling evil guys
you're truly enabling evil and this is
why you see people on the hard left who
feel no shame at defending but openly
offending just terrible behavior so long
as the person who's engaging in the
terrible behavior is a member of a
victimized minority group it truly is
amazing like what people are willing to
go along with for example there's this
football player named Sean Jackson right
DeSean Jackson is a is a wide receiver
for the Philadelphia Eagles very
talented guy he also happens to be
apparently a rabid anti-semite who is
fond of quoting Hitler on his on his
Instagram page which is always a delight
okay he quoted Hitler he quoted Louis
Farrakhan we already know that IceCube
does that's right there was all this
blowback for about 24 hours about
IceCube does anyone actually think
IceCube won't be hired up to play a part
any time in the next year or two
imagine somebody white in Hollywood
quoting Hitler about the Jews and think
whether that person would would be hired
any time in the near future I did at
least lose a decade right Mel Gibson
lost a decade of his career because he
did this sort of stuff right but if you
are if you're on the left and you are on
the hard left and you're a person of
color you can basically say what you
want about the Jews so DeSean Jackson is
quoting openly quoting Hitler and
Shannon Sharpe the former tight end for
the Denver Broncos and bleep bringing
Bay Packers at one point
Shannon Sharpe he comes out and defends
DeSean Jackson and Louis Farrakhan on
national television hey because this is
the the radical life does not have to
have it only have to abide by their own
rules the only rule is domination of
power don't have to abide by their anti
bigotry rules after all they're moving
in pursuit of the destruction of the
system and if that means a lying with
people like DeSean Jackson they'll do it
here here is Shannon Sharpe defending
DeSean Jackson where where the calls to
boycott first to boycott undisputed
right really if this happened on Fox
News right not on Fox Sports if this
happened on Fox News and it was
right-wingers talking about excusing
pro-hitler commentary from a white guy
how fast with the boycotts mobilized
weird sleeping giants be but here
Shannon Sharpe defending Louis Farrakhan
and defending DeSean Jackson by the way
my favorite is that Shannon Sharpe
tweeted out where where Jews defending
people when they use when they say stuff
like this wait what you want the Jews to
defend a guy who's quoting Hitler I'm
kind of confusion here a Shannon Sharpe
defending to Sean Jackson no matter what
you think a Louis Farrakhan Nation of
Islam he has made it pretty clear over
the years he does not like Jewish people
is that fair to say well not from the
conversation that
I've had with with the minister he said
it's abundantly he's made it clear to
anybody just sitting down sat down with
him he says he doesn't the House
Representative Omar right he said it was
all about the Benjamins
they jumped all over her President Trump
said the exact same thing you guys won't
vote for me because you care about their
money and you can't control me he said
the exact same thing nobody said a word
yeah I love the what about ISM on behalf
of Luis marathon really solid stuff
there from Shannon chart bottom line is
if you're on the proper side of left all
defenses are available to you if you're
not on the proper side of left no
defenses are available to you and again
the the cultural commanding Heights have
been captured by the radical left to the
point where
bloviating idiots like Chelsea Handler
are fully compliant with the line right
the new line is it's time to dismantle
the entire system here is Chelsea
Handler talking about this yesterday
coming to the realization that my
success has a lot to do with my skin
color I wanted to really do something
that set an example about how to you
know contribute because at this point
it's not enough to just say you're not
racist you know you have to be what we
have to be working to dismantle the
system because we are reaping the
benefits and exchange for people losing
benefits we have to we have to dismantle
the system okay when you've got the
entire culture echoing the message it's
time to not just work within the system
the old liberal line right not to change
the system to dismantle the system to
funtom it to fundamentally transform the
system right then you got a problem now
cheers this is why now the line that is
being used about Joe Biden right now is
pretty damn dishonest Joe Biden is gonna
be a bulwark against these folks you can
get to that in just one second first
it's literally never a bad idea to save
money and now would be like the best
time ever to save money shopping for
life insurance can raise a lot of
questions like how much coverage do you
need which insurance company is the best
one for you how much should it even cost
and at a time when it's important then a
more important than ever to have life
insurance the pandemic is making it a
little more complicated to shop for but
policy genius can help you as a life
insurance marketplace backed by a team
of experts policy genius is keeping
track of all the changes in the market
so you don't have to they'll find you
the right amount of coverage at the best
possible price without the headache
policy genius will compare quotes from
the top life insurance companies all in
one place it's just a few minutes to
compare quotes from those top insurers
and find at your best price doesn't just
save a lot of legwork you could say 1500
bucks or more a year by using policy
genius to compare life insurance
policies once you apply the policy
genius team handles all the paperwork
and the red tape for free so if you hit
any speed bumps during the application
process they will be there to take care
of everything by the way if you don't
have home insurance or if you're
overpaying for any of that disability
insurance auto insurance policy genius
will do all of that for you get it done
in adult if you need life insurance but
you're not sure where to start
head on over to policy genius com policy
genius will help you find the best rate
and handle the process completely I'll
get you and your family protected and
covered and give you one less thing to
worry about check them out today policy
genius calm okay
in just a second we are going to get to
the Joe Biden of it all because the left
kinda wants to have it both ways right
Joe Biden was nominated on the basis of
the liberal promise not the hard left
promise but can Americans trust that Joe
Biden is gonna be a bulwark against this
sort of stuff in other words with Joe
Biden have signed the canceled cultural
letter or would be beyond the Ezra Klein
side basically pooh-poohing canceled
culture pretending it doesn't exist and
suggesting that if you care about free
speech it's about relationships of power
right where does Joe Biden lie here and
can Joe Biden be trusted to basically
stop the radicalism of a movement that
wants to tear it all down we'll get to
that in just one second first if you're
not already a daily why remember you
should consider getting a readers past a
daily wire.com it's a great value for
only three bucks a month when you sign
up you get that first month for only 99
cents they also get access to our mobile
app articles and free access to
exclusive editorials like this one from
Christian Toto shut up the celebrity
said hoping the PC police would spare
them so if you haven't checked out the
readers pass already head on over to
Daley we're not comment sign up for just
about people are really enjoying it also
I have a great book pitch for you ready
for this I know you've heard about my
book a little bit it's my book how to
destroy America in three easy steps
you're watching it like enacted step by
step but my book is really the response
so the attempts to destroy America and
what you should do in order to stop that
it really is an activism manual
philosophical activism manual for how to
fight back against the leftist lies
about the disintegration astray is what
I call them people who want to destroy
our common heritage the disintegration
is lies about American history America's
culture of rights America's philosophy
right all of those things are under
assault how to destroy America in three
easy steps
it is easily the most relevant book good
moment I mean there's just no question
about it I didn't think it's gonna be
that relevant when I wrote it it is far
more relevant now than when I wrote it
back in December and January you can go
check that out right now you can
pre-order a signed copy at Daley we're
calm at /ban you can even ask me a
question with your purchase which could
be read aloud during my live signing
events on the day of the book release
it's a lot of good stuff happening with
that book that book comes out July it's
once you first go pre-order your signed
copy right now and make sure that you
are one of the first to receive it at
daily wire.com at /bin I am busily
signing copies as we speak
go check everything out right now at
daily wire com so I spent and pick up a
copy of how to destroy America in three
easy steps right now and listening to
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
all righty so Ken Joe Biden be trusted
to stop the march of the radical left so
remember Bernie Sanders was gonna be the
guy there you go all the way back to
February Bernie Sanders was sort of the
apotheosis of all of this he was the
pinnacle of it I mean he was having
rallies where he literally had
indigenous people get on stage and talk
about how the rally was taking place on
solon on stolen Native American land and
he was going up there and apologizing
for America's history he was going up
there and suggesting that America's
entire system was thoroughly corrupt and
evil and had to be torn down and built
anew and the stuff that Bernie Sanders
talked about so all the kind of most
radical stuff that you're hearing right
now about Mount Rushmore and tearing
down statues Bernie was a head of that
stuff my Bernie had already made his
peace with the radical racial left and
he had made the Alliance and then Joe
Biden waltzed to the nomination because
it turns out most Americans are still
not up for this so the great lie that
this is what the liberals really should
be resisting along the lines of is that
the old promise is still kind of true
which is you can't win accept that who
the radical left thinks they can win and
that they're going to use Joe Biden as
their vehicle for winning so Joe is Joe
Biden a captured vehicle is really the
question of the moment for the 2020
election because Joe Biden basically won
the primaries by saying I'm not burning
and most Democrats were like you know
what we could use a not Bernie in order
to win but as Trump becomes more
unpopular and the radical left gains
more and more credence in the culture
wars the radical left has been able as
I've been talking about to suggest that
it does have the power to win elections
on its own without the soft-pedaling of
people like Joe Biden and here's the
problem for Joe Biden Joe Biden
basically knows it right Joe Biden
secretly and not not quite that secretly
he's making overtures to the radical
left and he's still making noises about
how he's gonna be sort of a bulwark but
we know that the bulwark doesn't really
exist in the same way that Barack Obama
in 2008 was suggesting that he was very
much Pro traditional marriage when
everybody basically knew that he was
lying everybody kind of knew he'd
already talked about it in 2006-2007
that he was Pro same-sex marriage but in
2008 running for president he was like I
don't think the American people are
ready for that so I know I'll just lie
and he went out there and he's like I'm
Pro traditional marriage in fact the
same election that elected Barack Obama
basically brought a proposition in
California to
Wishon prop aids that protected
traditional marriage and was largely on
the back of black votes right a lot of
black voters voted for Obama and also
voted to preserve traditional marriage
and those were not in conflict in 2008
because Barack Obama was saying he was
for traditional marriage in 2008 so now
it feels kind of the same thing with Joe
Biden and him standing up for quote
America's values in America's history
right Joe Biden was asked would you tear
down statues and he said well I would
let them tear down the Confederate
statues but I wouldn't tear down statues
of Washington Jefferson and and Columbus
which is by the way the sort of
mainstream American position it's a
holding pattern isn't it isn't it a
holding pattern like do you think that
Joe Biden is is genuine they're two
questions is Joe Biden genuine when he
says that sort of stuff that he's gonna
provide some sort of wall against the
radical left destroying our culture from
within turning us into a sensorial now
struggle session shaming culture is he
gonna be with the people who signed this
Harper's letter or is he gonna be on the
side of the people who are attacking the
people who signed the Harper's letter or
is he just going to enable those people
or he's just gonna stand back and let it
happen and my bet is on the third buddy
Joe Biden will say whatever he has to do
to get elected a Joe Biden is not gonna
be an activist on behalf of traditional
American history philosophy or culture
or the one comes right down to it if Joe
Biden thought he could get away with
signing into law
I hate speech regulation I think Joe
Biden would probably do it I think that
if Joe Biden thought he could get away
with signing into law slavery
reparations I think Joe Biden would
probably do it he wants to be seen as a
historic figure you're not seen as a
historic figure for holding the line
you're seen as a historic figure on the
left for radically changing things okay
and the best indicator that Joe Biden is
really not what he is campaigning as
which is you can trust me I'm not gonna
change too much I'm an old dead guy
I'm not even alive I'm Joe Biden and I'm
not
the best indicator this is not the case
is what's happening right now with the
Democratic Party platform so as Steve
guest from the from the GOP points out
the Biden platform has is purely ripping
off Bernie at this point
surely ripping him off so Biden has
picked up the the Bernie criminal
justice unity task force idea he just
picked it up directly from Bernie's
platform like word for word
he's plagiarizing I mean Joe Biden is
famous for plagiarizing but he's now
plagiarizing Bernie Sanders his platform
straight Biden copied Bernie's workplace
democracy plan straight word-for-word
his economic agenda copies directly from
Bernie's disability rights agenda
heightened social security agenda is
copied directly word-for-word from
Bernie Sanders's agenda
that that's the story here is that well
Biden is posing himself as this kind of
moderate Democrat you can feel safe with
he's the he's the return to normalcy
candidate right Donald Trump to this
wild crazy guy but here I am barely
alive and I'm not gonna change all that
much and we'll all go back to our daily
lives and this craziness will end that's
not where this is going that's not where
this is going you know who knows this is
not where this is going Bernie so Bernie
was on MSNBC he said listen we have been
able to basically shovel our entire
platform into Biden's platform but
Bernie said on MSNBC with Chris Hayes he
said Biden could be the most progressive
president since FDR here's what it
sounded like and these folks leave the
society people are represented the
progressive movement had a different
perspective on things than did Biden's
people but there was serious discussion
and I think a real honest in epic to
come up with a compromise and I think
the compromise that they came up with if
implemented will make Biden the most
progressive president since FDR so as
you can hear Bernie is sounding pretty
happy there right Bernie has engaged an
institutional capture and the
institutional capture is complete and
Biden is now a tool of the radical left
and this is one of the reasons by the
way well I think that it's very likely
that Biden is going to avoid debate with
Trump who's I think Trump could simply
ask him some very simple questions some
very simple questions he could ask him
do you believe that America was founded
in 1776 or in 1619 right do you believe
that America was founded on slavery do
you think that America that America was
an incredible system marred by the great
sin of slavery or do you think that
America's systems are rooted in slavery
do you believe in slavery reparations
right do you believe that the cops
should be defunded as so many members of
your own party seemed to have suggested
do you think the cops are endemically
racists forget about defunding them do
you think that their system that they
are systemically racist and targeting
black Americans right that there are a
thousand things that Biden could be
asked that are part of the radical left
so gender fighting doesn't want to be
asked those questions because his entire
goal here is to elide those questions in
very much the same way that Barack Obama
was able to alive many of the questions
about his own radicalism in 2008
hey Brock Obama was very good at this
Biden is not quite as as quick on his
feet as Barack Obama was circa 2008 also
he's not faced with an opponent who was
quite as conciliatory as John McCain in
2008 in 2008 John McCain was not willing
to ask Barack Obama any self questions
Donald Trump has no limits and we'll ask
Joe Biden pretty much anything on a
debate stage which is why I think it is
quite likely that Biden actually just
does not debate Trump I think that
especially with coronavirus I think it
is quite possible that Joe Biden
basically says I'm not sedating Trump
and there's no reason for me to debate
Trump I'm up double digits in the polls
right now cook Political Report switch
is a fairly I would say cautious
cautious organization cook Political
Report basically says Biden's won the
election already according to cook
Political Report just looking at and
they rank sort of states lean Republican
lean Democrats solidly Democrat they say
that Biden is already locked up 275
electoral votes they basically called
the race already it's July I know that
could change but Trump's gonna have to
pull the rabbit out of the Hat one of
the rabbits he's gonna have to pull out
of the Hat is a debate in which he just
clocks Biden across the head and so
Biden's best move here is to avoid all
these questions right Biden's best move
here because you know he's gonna pick
somebody radical right for his VP
there's just no way he's gonna pick
somebody who is not in some sense
radical like the least radical candidate
on his list is Susan Rice which does not
speak very highly of the non radicalism
of your list
but Thomas Friedman is openly suggesting
now in the New York Times that Biden
should not debate Trump unless Trump
releases his tax returns for 2016
through 2018 which of course Trump is
probably not going to do and second
Biden should insist as Thomas Friedman
on a real-time fact-checking team
approved by both candidates be hired by
the nonpartisan Commission on
Presidential Debates and that ten
minutes before the scheduled conclusion
of the debate this team report on any
misleading statements phony numbers or
outright lies either candidate had
uttered okay there's no way Trump's
gonna agree to that because there is no
possible way if you come up with an
actual bipartisan fact-checking team
approved by both candidates it doesn't
work that way I mean that check the
fact-checking organizations the
fact-checking organizations are
dominated by the left there may be two
fact-checking organizations on the right
and they're very very small outfits so
basically Thomas Friedman is setting a
bar that he knows that that from will
never clear such that Biden will never
have to debate him so that's the goal
here
the goal here is to wander through Biden
the radical left to use Biden as the
final sort of moderate elderly dies for
what's coming next
everybody knows this right Biden himself
has said if he's a transitional figure
he has said this openly he's the only
candidate in my lifetime who's openly
proclaimed that he's not running for
president he's running to be the guy
who's before the next president that's a
pretty amazing statement but it also
happens to have a ring of truth to it so
all the people in the this is why
Trump's being off-putting is so bad for
him frankly because of Trump or anything
but the kind of off-putting candidate he
is there'd be a lot of people liberals
who might be inclined to think okay well
I got to think about the alternative
here
it's funny I was talking to somebody
yesterday who again is working inside
one of these organizations that's
currently experiencing the purge and I
said to him have you thought about
voting for Trump said I could never vote
for Trump he said I could never vote for
Trump and I said well you do realize
that Trump might be the last bulwark
against the people who are trying to you
know cleanse the culture he said right
but I could never bring myself to vote
for Trump and this is the biggest
problem for President Trump is that the
conditions are lined up for Trump not
just to win to win enormous you've got
an entire culture of people who wish to
wipe out the livelihoods of an entire
side of the political aisle and claim
their racist without any evidence
and somehow Trump the least politically
correct president ever is going to blow
this if he does it's one of the great
political sins in American history if
that if that happens all right look I
understand that now Trump is the
underdog again and so we got to play the
game where Trump is being bad at about
the years by the media and it's none of
it's his fault he was always bad at
about the years by the media that isn't
his fault
what is his fault is the fact that he's
become so off-putting to so many people
that the left can riot
send crime skyrocketing in every major
American city cancel everyone in the
culture including people who are just
moderate liberals and somehow he
receives no political benefit from that
I mean that that's that's a pretty
damning indictment how he's running his
campaign he better turn this ship around
you better turn it around fast because
it's my belief that Joe Biden is not
gonna be any sort of bulwark against the
radical left and not only won't show by
to be a radical bore or a bulwark I
think that he's going to exacerbate the
the gains of the radical left by
laundering their ideology into the
mainstream
and if that makes that makes Trump
selection a lot more important not a lot
less important so you should be upset
with him he's down ten points at this
point okay quick commentary on piece of
good news I may as well not say a couple
piece of good news here so the Supreme
Court actually gave a couple of good
seven to two decisions yesterday there
were two decisions on this one of the
one of the decisions was about the the
contraception mandate so the Little
Sisters of the Poor got dragged up again
in front of the Supreme Court for the
great sin of nuns not providing birth
control in their health care coverage
and 72 the Supreme Court said not
they're nuns they can pretty much do
that that's okay so according to the New
York Times the Supreme Court upheld the
Trump administration regulation that
lets employers with religious or moral
objections limit women's access to birth
control coverage under the Affordable
Care Act naturally near attempts has
could result in as many as a hundred and
twenty six thousand women losing
contraceptive coverage from their
employers because we have to force
people to violate their most dearly held
principles I was amused to see people
very very angry at nuns yesterday that
was pretty incredible I did that
literally this woman tweeted out there's
a picture of the nuns from Little
Sisters of the Poor speaking to the
press and said nuns the people that we
should listen to on birth control just
thought you the person I should listen
to are nuns and then so that was a good
decision that's that's good it's it's
good that at least sometimes you get
good decisions from the Supreme Court
the other one is a 72 decision in which
Chief Justice Roberts sided with the
courts conservatives so did Elena Kagan
and Steven Breyer the two radicals on
the court like really truly radicals are
Ginsburg and Sotomayor they are always
taking the most radical position the
case before the court involves two
Catholic schools st. James Catholic
school and Our Lady of Guadalupe a
Catholic school that dismissed employees
who later sued is emily is an oddity
writing for daily wire religious
institutions have a ministerial
exemption that allows them leeway in
hiring and firing and protection from
employment discrimination suits the case
before the Supreme Court tested whether
there was a specific limits the
ministerial exemption so if you are an
English teacher at a Catholic Church at
a Catholic school can you engage it can
you be transgender and be protected on
that basis from firing
for example the ministerial exception
says yes you can because if you are
working for a Catholic school the
assumption is that you're going to abide
by Bakley basic Catholic principles at
least while you are in school if Fox
News reports the decision covered to
cases involving teachers at religious
who claimed that they were discriminated
against in one egg miss Morris Ribeiro
alleged that a Roman Catholic school in
LA did not renew her contract because of
her age she tried a variety of subjects
including religion but didn't have any
religious training or title prior to
working there she did take religious
education classes at the school's
request once she was working there and
prayed with students in a second clay
case woman and Christian Biel claimed
she was let go from another la Catholic
school because she asked to take leave
due to breast cancer treatments she too
taught multiple subjects including
religion prayed with students despite
not having a formal religious title in
the Supreme Court affirmed that
religious organizations have broad
protection against employment
discrimination suits Alito noted the
court could not carve out loopholes to
the exemptions or they would basically
moot the exemption so this is more in
line with the suggestion by my friends
David French that what justice Gorsuch
was doing in the LGBT civil rights case
is who's basically making it so that
unless you are a church you cannot fire
people on this basis so if you're just a
religious person in regular life you
can't fire somebody on the basis of
same-sex marriage for example but if you
are a religious organization you can
which again is a distinction I think is
really not protected by the Constitution
or by the Civil Rights Act but it's it's
what has been called the Utah compromise
it's something that Utah has pressed
forward with with a lot of robustness in
in law ok we'll be here tomorrow with a
bunch of additional content including
your updates on everything covered
related President Trump is now in debate
with Anthony Falchi about whether
schools should reopen there's good
evidence from Europe the brief stories
there's good evidence from Europe and
schools reopening is not endangering the
kids in the schools the big problem is
what do you do with the teachers the
answer might be you have to hire some
younger teachers because if you don't
want to endanger the teachers but you
also want kids to be able to go to
school which kind of is vital at this
point then you might have to just put in
teachers who are less health well neural
that might be a possible solution here
we'll get to more of it tomorrow because
hope it ain't going away so I'm sure
that we will still be talking about it
tomorrow
in the meantime hang in there and we'll
see you then I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas executive producer Jeremy
boring supervising producer
Mathis Glover and Robert Stirling
assistant director Pavel why douse key
technical producer austin stevens
playback and media operated by Nick
Sheehan associate producer Katie Swinton
edited by Adam sy events audio is mixed
by micro Romina hair and makeup is by
Anika Geneva the Ben Shapiro show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 Joe Biden mutters
incoherently Don Lemon shows us why the
left can't meme and the Supreme Court
magnanimously allows a group of nuns to
pray another day check it out on the
Michael Knoll show
[Music]
you